vous êtes le papa non je suis complet
c'est papa du bébé chanteur sur scène on
fait du théâtre itinérant c'est le genre
de métier dans lequel on doit pas
s'ennuyer
très bien alors si on coupe à tuer alors
j'en ai marre c'est une histoire de
famille où kwai et oui c'est une
histoire de famille et alors c'est quoi
ce chantier temps deux heures je veux
que tu sois nickel à un second derrière
normaux pour joie et propre temps déjà
personne ne vaut pas dans ces familles
les enfants rois des moindres
m
sur la tête de ma mère faisait des
malawites à sa voiture avant que tu es
devenu petit feu sans panache c'est ça
qu'on veut devenir c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est battu
oh
on
et
m